well maybe the best way in here is the
question of
what we call this phenomenon and my
feeling is and
frankly i faced this all the way back in
2017
right i find the world is now catching
up to the question of
whether you call them protesters or
rioters is
essential and what i've been saying very
clumsily for all of these years
is i call the thing that showed up in my
classroom
you know at 10 in the morning on may
23rd
uh that was a protest and i say it
quickly devolved into riots which it did
they were barricading buildings they
were kidnapping
uh members of the administration they
assaulted people they
had the police stood down and then they
wandered the campus with weapons
um so the point is protest and riot both
have a relevance but it's actually a
temporal shift
is what happened and the same thing
happens here in portland with a twist
which is there is a protest
that happens every night and it
predictably
turns into a riot and so in a sense this
isn't even
the situation in that happened at
evergreen where things plausibly
escalated
this is actually a plan and in some
sense the
protest is there to be captured for
those who are reporting to an audience
that wants to hear
that portland is finally standing up
against police brutality
and that the feds are coming in to you
know to
institute some kind of fascist thing and
they've been repelled by the protesters
who valiantly
confronted them or something like that
if you're you know msnbc
then the point is you know what time to
show up to see
a protest that's a protest but if you
are engaged in a protest that you know
for sure
is going to become a riot later in the
evening you're actually signing up for
responsibility
for that riot that's my opinion so i'm
going to walk back a little bit what
of what i said in terms of the stories
in the middle i think the story is
all over i think that all of these
things can be true at the same time
and i'm going to agree with you that say
yes you know
because there were people that are sort
of in the middle i mean there really
were people that are like i'm really
want to do something to try to make it
better so you know black men are not
killed i mean they really
are trying but they're not the people
really around anymore and i i actually
don't think i mean
not from what i've seen i was in
portland all last week for about a week
and a half
the the sort of more peaceful protests
they've really died down
you really don't see those anymore those
people are not marching
anymore in front of the building i did
see a nice um
cavalcade of cars one night going
through northeast portland that was
super peaceful you know they're
kind of with flags and tooting and you
know they're part of the community too
but all of that is sort of now receded
what we have consistently every now
every day now
except not last night weirdly and
there's some questions about why that
was
uh is we have
the uh black bloc which is the sort of
you know
antifa s arm that believes in you know
you know by any method including
violence um
and we've got some black lives matter
protesters we've got some
randos we've got some hot heads we've
got some people that are confused
um and they do have a plan and i know
that
because i uh i have been speaking with
several of them
but they're not supposed to talk to you
but they do sometimes because people
need to tell you their stories
and they definitely do have a plan and
their plan
is basically to get the populace
of portland to mistrust the police
enough that it's not just a matter maybe
of defunding
it's a matter of the police are not
going to be people that you're going to
call because you don't trust them
anymore and
also because they can't respond
right yep portland is already down
i think it's about 500 officers than
they should be
and then they've got people that are
retiring early because who the heck
wants to be a portland police officer in
portland and yeah
right now or they're just resigning and
getting the hell out of there and doing
something else
um so you're down 500 officers right and
then you can't tr
you can't replace them like you can't
replace them fast enough
especially especially if you're
defunding because the obvious
way to replace police officers who are
fleeing in droves
is to make it a more attractive
job effectively pay them for hazard pay
so you're cutting the police at the same
point you're demonizing them
which is going to result in fewer worse
police
and it's going to increase the brutality
because the point is the brutality is a
substitute
for resources so now we had that
horrible incident
about a week and a half ago when that
guy was pulled out of his car
and you know beaten downtown and
i was out i think it was the following
night or two nights later and i was
hanging out with some black bloc
kids it was an interesting piece it's up
on reason uh
and this one kid who i don't know if he
mistook me for one of his like press
people or if he just wanted to talk
but he did and i said to him so listen i
know that you know
antifa doesn't you know reign in anybody
else everybody do their own thing
different groups you might not be in
charge of this
what do what do they think about what
happened downtown that guy getting
beaten and he said to me
you know what the cops know who those
kids are those are the 7-eleven kids
and they should have been there and i
was like yeah but they're chasing you
all around
town right and he kind of looked at his
shoes
and with a not very anarchistic
sensibility he said yeah but they should
have been there
but how can they be there i mean someone
told me the other day their car got
stolen and they called the cops the cops
are like sorry
nothing we could do about it and if they
had been there
there is no question in my mind that it
would have been
filmed and portrayed as
an abuse of power so
right it's an opportunity it's an
opportunity uh
to make the police look bad at every
turn
and um this is very deliberate this is
you know
being built right now narratively with
people's iphones
that's that's what's happening it is the
construction of a false
narrative over things that kind of
happened
sort of happened right you can piece
together a very false story
out of things you know out of edits
basically the editor
is you know the editor rules the
narrative in the video age
and um the problem is
i mean first of all this black bloc
thing goes on
all the time in the pacific northwest
it's a feature of the landscape
right and it is larping i believe but
um the idea that
a confused general
outpouring of anger and support after
george
floyd's death has now largely dried up
and something else has taken up the
mantle
but it was doing its thing before this
right it wasn't
absolutely it was about tearing down
civilization
from the beginning it's been demonizing
cops since
you know occupy and before yep right and
the point is it's just continuing to do
its thing
but now it has the attention of the
world and it has this
cloak that it is using which has to do
with
um protecting black people and improving
the quality of their lives
and it's unassailable right because if
you complain about it if you say guys
like why don't we sit at the table and
talk about
this then it's like well you're a racist
it's like well i'm not actually not like
that's that you know
they feel that whatever they're doing
now they have exact cloak is exactly
right
whatever they're gonna say is is
unassailable i'll tell you one more just
think just to get back to the editing
and then we'll
we'll we'll move on the first night i
was in portland last
month uh they were the federal building
stuff was really in high gear
and um they attacked the building for
about
three hours uh setting fires trash
burning barbecues this and that knocking
down fences
and um they actually then they you know
got in
and and were tearing off the plywood and
smashing it down with a fire
extinguisher something i filmed by the
way and when to show you what people
want to see when i put it online
somebody commented oh i can tell nancy
rommelman staged that in a studio
because you know
you can see the shininess on it i'm like
what are you talking
about but anyway it was about three
hours into that
before the feds shot out their first
tear gas
and everybody you know kind of ran away
once and they're pretty organized walked
on run walk don't run so people don't
get you know
uh stampeded and then you get into the
park and the girls can i wash your eyes
like they've got a little
pattern going but everybody was saying i
can't believe they tear gassed us i'm
like
guys you're setting fire to the building
for
three hours like do you you know
you want provocation you know you want
it so bad
you want them to respond to you so they
did
so stop complaining
[Music]
you